all right so this texas voting bill this
is really just bananas so i'm going to
start
by showing you some of the lies now you
know that white house press secretary
jensachi this woman
is an extraordinary liar she she should
get an award i don't know do they give
out an award for like
greatest liar like she should get the
greatest liar award maybe
you know i have a friend who does
ceramics and maybe we can put together a
little sign because this woman i want to
mail it
to the white house she just cannot say
anything true as i always say
if you asked her what her favorite color
was she would say for
like the woman is completely incapable
of saying anything that's true
and the new thing that all the democrats
are doing is lying about
all of these voter laws that are
happening in these red states which
mostly are about having an id
to vote that's mostly what they're about
but i'm going to read you the actual
bullet points and tell you what it
really is about
but here's sake on what's going on in
texas right now
he'll also decry efforts to strip the
right to vote as authoritarian and
anti-american as a
and stand up against the notion that
politicians should be allowed to choose
their voters or to subvert our system by
replacing independent election
authorities with partisan ones
and he will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
and how we need to work together with
civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout and voter
education system to overcome
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war i guess they forgot
about that january 6th insurrection that
they said was the worst thing
since the civil war and they completely
forgot about 911 and everything else i
mean these people
are absolutely ridiculous uh the the top
line there
nobody is stripping the right to vote so
she's saying that in essence
you know the republicans are stripping
the right to vote from people
do you think there's any republican is
there any mainstream conservative
republican anyone in america
that does not want legal citizens to
vote have you heard anyone say that
have you heard we're going to strip the
right to vote
from legal citizens nobody is saying
that but that's what they say
over and over now before i get to the
specifics that are in the build the
specifics that they
never mention by the way and if if uh
you know what's his name over at fox
who's the fox reporter that's usually in
there
ducey right peter ducey who i think is a
fine reporter
uh peter ducey if you're if you're
watching this by chance maybe you want
to ask
in tomorrow's press conference hey jen
can you give me the specific
thing the specific quote in the bill
that is the thing
that is an effort to strip the right to
vote etc etc like because if it's really
all about ids then we can have an
interesting debate
about ids again you have to show id to
go mini golfing right you have to show
id to get a beer and go on a plane
uh but it's not just gensake that's
lying they all lie
endlessly here's chuck schumer this
morning in a democracy
no right is more sacred than the right
to vote
and yet across the country
republican-controlled state legislatures
are conducting the most sweeping and
coordinated attack on voting rights in
generations
fueled by donald trump's insidious big
lie
that the election was stolen republican
legislatures are not only making it
harder to vote they're making it easier
to steal an election actually believe
that
donald trump does the big lie everyone
knows it's a lie
and now republican legislatures are
acting on that big lion saying we could
steal an election
what is happening to our democracy
what is happening to our democracy
you're quite right chuck schumer you
are happening to our democracy and you
are a liar and we know you're a liar and
you know that we know you're a liar and
you keep lying
uh he says that these attacks these are
a sweeping and coordinated attack
on voting rights so okay
i thought dave that's pretty
that's pretty intense to say something
like that a sweeping attack
on voting rights so you know what we're
going to read you some bullet points
about what is
actually in hb3 this texas
voting law we've got some quotes here
from the national review i believe there
are nine bullet points
and then we'll jump in and unpack the
legislation pushes back against what
we're supposed to be temporary
expedience during the pandemic
such as drive-through voting and 24-hour
early voting marathon so i'm going to
just comment on each one very quickly as
we go through this so okay so first off
what they're saying is they're pushing
back on some of the things that we had
to do because of covid so things that we
always did
and then we changed some of it because
of cobit so so far no we're not
sweeping taking away anything okay so
that's number one
number two it explicitly forbids
election officials implementing
practices not contemplated
under the state's election statutes as
sometimes happened during the pandemic
okay so meaning election officials
aren't allowed to do things that they're
not allowed
to do okay under the pandemic i guess
some stuff
happened i don't even know exactly what
happened but i have no doubt that there
were some
hijinks right but basically they're
saying we have statutes on how we run
elections and you're gonna have to stick
to those statutes all right we're two
for two uh
three in many counties it will extend
the daily minimum time for having early
voting by one hour
early voting i thought everybody loves
early voting we're extending early
voting
okay pretty good that's three four in
certain circumstances
employers are required to give employees
time off to go vote
my god this is evil this is just
extraordinarily evil
next one among other things it would
require voters to write a
driver's license number or other
identifier
on absentee ballots matching the
existing voter id
requirement for registering to vote and
voting in person okay so if you've got
an id
a driver's license or some other id
we're just gonna have some ability to
prove that you are you racist
uh then it would ban public officials
from sending out
unsolicited mail-in ballots a
common-sense provision
to keep excess ballots from floating
around so this was one of the things
during covert people were just sending
out ballots all over the place i got
several ballots here
it's just a way of trying to control the
amount of ballots going out not saying
don't
send ballots to certain people right but
we're not going to have
partisan people just send out a
gajillion ballots next
it would mandate that all voting systems
have a paper trail
on or before 2026 with a funding
incentive for counties to comply early
a paper trail well that would be pretty
good because you know we're used to
ipads and touch screens and you kind of
press things and does anything really
happen
so a paper trail is a little printer
that's in the machine
that allows you to know afterwards
because you have a physical thing a
piece of paper with
it's been printed on that shows you that
the vote actually counted
uh and then finally for sizable
jurisdictions that can easily pull it
off it would require
live streaming of voting counting
proceedings
so that sounds pretty good so then
everybody votes people show ids we make
sure everyone followed the policies etc
etc and then using this thing that came
out about 20 years ago a webcam
we're going to stick a little logitech
webcam up in the corner
and we're gonna make sure that people
aren't you know taking big pieces of
paper and moving them here and shifting
them here and changing things and all
sorts of stuff
guys did any of that did any of that
seem like a sweeping assault on voter
rights did any of that
seem like an assault on democracy did
any of that seem like
the greatest attack since the civil war
or whatever nonsense
that crazy woman just said but these are
the people we are dealing with
they don't mind lying about everything
because they know the media is not going
to do
anything they know they simply will no
it's not that they won't do anything
they will propagate
and promulgate that's your word of the
day they will promulgate
that lie okay